yes Rosie all day today we're gonna be
drinking all day we're gonna be drinking
five ounces of Rose a every hour on the
hour and then we're also gonna follow it
up with water I personally love Rosie
and I'm a tank this is gonna be like an
easy breeze for me
cheers Rosie number one 9:00 a.m. we're
gonna start bougie but I'm telling you
my boo she gets boozy real quick
ah I'm already starting to feel my why
is it to better I want better for you
hashtag right okay just finish my first
glass this gonna be a good day
you're already tipsy enough to have
attempted this clip but it didn't work
out could you do this actually press
room excuse me man second glass of wine
of the day that's what's the jug I feel
great I have a meeting and hope people
don't notice that I'm drunk at this
meeting on a scale of 1 to drunk how
would you rate me pretty drunk
[Music]
it's a French wine imported and Stanford
Connecticut it really tastes them the
tannins yes this one tastes like I put a
penny in my mouth let's give them food
ok pity is my good sister Adriana's
giving me a tie-pin
unless you help me kids we're you guys
too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
special guests welcome to Rosie's a
older I've ever had Rosie before I'm not
drunk I am sober yeah yeah caca de caca
de caca de go not drunk I am sick I
don't want to be a buzz feed I go from
Bujji - Bujji real quick I can't come to
your party I'm on house arrest Real
Housewives
3 p.m. I am yeah I got us some
electrolytes you're putting the baby
like I can tear why and raise up the VP
today Oh times Rosie all day is to our
children may they have rich parents
I don't know for having conquered
today's challenge yes I feel like my
recoil effect was they all day hashtag
y'all are lying to your face no one
should do Rosie all day